if anyone in this theater commits an act
of violence at any point during the show
you will be awarded the Oscar for best
actor
there's an elephant in the room you have
to say hey look at that it's an elephant
and that elephant the slap heard round
the world
oh wow you don't know when something
crazy might happen and crazy things seem
to be happening a lot lately Jimmy
Kimmel wastes no time and gets into it
during his monologue at the 2023 Oscars
five Irish actors are nominated tonight
which means the odds of another fight on
stage just went way up
the comedian reminds everyone that last
year on Hollywood's biggest night was
pretty awkward if anything unpredictable
or violent happens during the ceremony
just do what you did last year nothing
there and do absolutely nothing
maybe even give the assailant a hug if
anyone in this theater commits an act of
violence at any point during the show
you will be awarded the Oscar for best
actor
and permitted to give a 19-minute long
speech I'll run if somebody comes up on
stage and I'm pretty fast so I think I'm
going to be okay and if any of you get
mad at a joke and decide you want to
come up here and get jiggy with it
it's not going to be easy you're a few
of my friends are going to have to get
through first you're going to get have
to get through the heavyweight champ
Adonis Creed Michelle yo the Mandalorian
Spider-Man you are gonna have to tangle
with Fable man
no punches were thrown on stage this
year but Jimmy threw plenty of A-list
Jabs I am happy to see that Nicole
Kidman has finally been released from
that abandoned AMC
where she has been held captive for
almost two full years now
heartbreak feels good in a place like
that thank you for encouraging people
who were already at the movie theater to
go to the movie theater really just have
to be funny at the beginning and then
funny throughout the whole thing the
sequel to Avatar it's the most expensive
movie ever made Disney spent two billion
dollars on this movie Just To Break Even
all of Nick Cannon's kids had to see
Avatar four times
well Nick wasn't at the ceremony but
Margot Robbie definitely heard this joke
a TV show can't lose a hundred million
dollars
is the gang from Babylon here they know
I've hosted the Oscars twice before and
I feel like I have a pretty good sense
of what needs to be done yeah we
remember the first time Jimmy emceed the
Academy Awards the same year we
experienced another massive blunder
Rihanna has a nine-month-old backstage
and he's very cute he pooped during
rehearsal you know the last person who
pooped backstage at the Oscars was that
accountant who mixed up the envelopes
there's a mistake
Moonlight you guys won best picture
personally I blame Steve Harvey for this
people have been asking is there going
to be any trouble this year and we
certainly hope not but if there is I
think the decision to go with the
champagne carpet rather than a red
carpet shows how confident we are that
no blood will be shed
[Music]
foreign